this is a production of Cornell
University
okay hello everyone I mean today I'm
going to talk to you about linear
underlying soil measurement and I'm
going to look at it from two
perspectives including being a vine
physiological perspective as well as
vineyard soil microbial grade microbial
and wine fermentation microbial
precession so if you look at a picture
you will notice that fair cylinder vine
for a closer picture so maintaining bare
soil under mine is the most popular
linear measurement practice in our
region and the reason for that is we
basically heritage this from the juice
grape industry where they needed a
larger vine to support higher yield but
for a wine grape industry this is a
excessive vigor it's a problem
people are just sent in their crews to
do hedging model things to do leapling
multiple times just to control the vine
bigger so you know that this is not a
very favourable kind of mentioned
practice in our wine grape industry and
plus there's a research done by our
group by mr. Adam Carroll who's not here
today who found that using glyphosate to
maintain bare soil and Irvine in
vineyard for long turn you increase the
amount of a nutrient bleaching and also
the pesticide leaching and soil leachate
so overall speaking is this is not
really simple for a lot of the wine
grape vineyard and we are looking for a
good alternative so many people study
that using undermine cover crops as the
alternative and they found that under
vine cover crop can reduce fine vigor
through water and nutrient competition
but those studies were done in young Ben
Urich
so what happening in a mature vineyard
for with those vines with
um well it's a well-established fruit
system so study done by our group again
um in a mature recently married we found
that under vine cover crops did not
impact on vine growth did not impact on
vine water nutrient status and do not
vary composition but what we found is
that when sensory properties wasn't was
were impacted and that is the really
make us think because if we don't get
the effect from the physiological
perspective what else can plain the
treat there and so we start getting
curious about the microbes so maybe
microbes is playing the trick there so
we want to study more to focus on the
microbial perspective in a beard so
these are our objectives we want to
evaluate how under vine cover crops
would affect on the vegetative growth
yelled food composition of a mature
Riesling vineyard aim finger lakes and
we want to determine how so your health
will be impacted by adopting different
undefined flows from flora management
practice so these are considered as the
physiological perspectives so we also
want to know that microbial perspective
so I want to see how formant flora
measurement practice would affect soil
great and also wine fermenting microbial
and finally we want to evaluate wine the
sensory property of the wine to see if
the wine sensory property are being
affected if so is this going through a
physiology a root or is going through
microbial roots
so our experimenter was contacted and at
Abbott New York sitting on the Howard
gravely loan with long term average
growth degree days around a thousand
three hundred seventy six based on
degree Celsius and the vineyard was
coming
we managed the vines armature vine so in
2014 they're around 14 to 15 years old
and the vines where Scott Henry changed
to 16 bucks per meter and these are the
treatments we use so GL y means
glyphosate so we spray glyphosate one to
two times per season depending on the
weed pressure and we also consider this
as our control the NR 2 treatments are
native natural vegetation so we have
previous MV which you basically just led
to we to grow under vine and we mow them
down whenever it's interfering the
fruiting zone and C ult which means soil
cultivation so we did it by using roto
tiller and cultivation for the hoe
experimental setup we adopt randomized
complete block design with each of the
treatment replicate for four times for
each of our experimental unit it
contains nine panels in three rows as
you can see here for each of the panel
contains three binds so there's nine
panels we only collect our sample from
the middle panel which is our data panel
because we're doing microbial work here
so we really want to have that that
physical and spatial barrier to prevent
the interfere that intervene coming from
outside of our experimental unit so
that's why we set up like this and this
so to be big enough do you have those
buffer so then let's look at the results
for first the physiological results so
vegetative growth we measured primary
shoot growth and lateral shoot growth
throughout the growing season for each
of the year for 2015-16 just remind you
that the experiment was set up in 2014
but when we collect the yelled and grave
data until
14 and it growth like Pacific growth we
only collect the data until than 15,000
16 so it was assessed in this two years
so the vegetative growth we use primary
and lateral shoot growth as an indicator
and as you can see here for a lateral
shoot growth we measure two went and
also the proportion of shoot that has
that had the lateral shoot and basically
we did not see any difference amount of
treatments just to remind you that at
our site our vine sorry there the vines
are huge and they're mature so they had
that really extensive really
well-established brew system so they
have it get assessed to those really
deep soil water and nutrients so it is
very reasonable to not seeing any
difference amount of treatment here it
turns out the vegetative growth and we
use midday stand water potential as an
indicator for the vine water status so
as measured as farce and we did not see
any difference amount of treatment in
2016 but in the late season 2015 I found
that natural vegetation and cultivation
basically divining those two treatments
had a more had higher stem water
potential compared to that of glyphosate
so the the the theory behind that is for
those two treatments they basically has
a soil surface protection so and in
native vegetation in 2015
around August we had very low rainfall
and then a lot of the weeds or stunt
growth so there is just hang out there
but they're not doing like a very
aggressive growing and for cultivation
after we do the cultivation the plant
procedures are just left on top of the
soil so those stuff just serve as a
surface cover like a mulch and they
protect
the surface soil water to evaporate it
evaporates so that means for those
things that got more of the surface soil
of water for a vine nutrient status we
took leaf petioles at Verizon for each
of the year we did not see any
difference among treatment in 2016 but
in 2015 we found that natural vegetation
basically increase amount of the alumni
and the petioles compared to glyphosate
so I think my theory behind this is for
those if you input all of your organic
matters and if there's a rescrew
actively growing in your soil that means
in a very small scale localized soil
there'd be soil acidification and that
freed up a lot of the free aluminum to
the plant so that's why we see this and
that's the theory back that I formed and
for natural vegetation that also reduce
the amount of magnums in the vine by 28
percent compared to the cultivation and
this can just purely due to the
competition and we also collect the
think yield and pruning weight so right
note it's very simple it's just how much
of the fruits for each fine we got so we
measured the amount of fruits for each
vine and we weigh it that's how we
measured the reproductive growth for the
vine and pruning weights so I'm going to
explain your pruning weight so and each
of the growing season after we harvest
and after the leaf all will prove we
prune the vine into the same shape with
same numbers of shoots and same number
of buds so just maintaining into the
same shape and those shoes got pruned
off we consider us as the fish
of the confirmed beard growth so we
weighed those shoots as our cream weight
so as you can see here those are the
shoe step Kuna and this guy's having
that backpack a weighing scale and we
just weigh the amount of shoes we prune
from the vine so that is the indicator
for the vegetative growth for each of
the vine so now we've got the gel from
the vine we've got a vegetative growth
of the vine we know we get an idea of
the balance between those reproductive
growth and vegetative growth however in
our study we found no difference amount
the yellow pruning weight and also the
ratio between them so there's no
difference so again because our vines
are huge and they have very deep roots
and so they got they have those
resources coming really deep down from
the soil so it is it is reasonable to
not see those differences in the mature
beam yure any basic conference are a
previous study so we also measure the
great basic composition parameters such
as bricks pH and total acidity a
previous TA here
so in general we don't see any
difference but in 2015 the cultivation
the great friend cultivation treatments
had a lower acidity if you look more
closely into the bricks for a 2015
cultivation here you will find that a
number it's really weird because when
the in a normal mature ation process
usually the brick the bricks the sugar
content is coupled with the lower amount
of acidity so when you get hired sugar
you get lower acidity but in this
treatment we found that the cultivation
the grapes from the cultivate
fifteen actually had a lower sugar and
also Loris it is very weird so what we
found is thank you on 15 we had a lot we
had some binding that treatment
specifically had little virus infection
so that's why that the couple of sugar
and acids happen and into on sixteen a
lot of those fines were naturally bad or
those fines that show the really severe
symptoms we see excluded for our
experience so in 2016 we see that a
number come back to normal but basically
we do not see any difference among the
treatments for those parameters and also
we assess sensory properties I know a
lot of you are very excited about this
data because a lot of you had contribute
to this and got the money out of it it's
so I the most important thing is you
will no longer you know do you remember
those days when you open your email
inbox and see 10 emails from me asking
you to do my sensory study and do you
remember that time when you see me in
the hallway like just sweaty and grumpy
trying to get people stuff in the room
to smell my stinky why I knew that you
get your freaked out because I look like
like but I going to use not going to
happen again because we've got all the
data here but unfortunately any is going
to do that in the near future so that's
a look at data I'm going to explain to
you how we did this for those few didn't
come to my sensory study thank you by
the way
so we basically a soda family peles to
smell through all the wines and then
sort the wine into groups based on their
aroma similarity so the wine says smells
the same to the panelists they just put
it into the sink ooh and then we assign
the score based on the grouping and then
we do we
collect all the data and then we
calculate the distance between or among
the samples and then we visualize the
soap we visualize it based on the
distant matrix so I know it's very it
sounds very confusing and it sounds very
complicated but what do you need to know
is that if the samples are closer
together that means they're a real mass
similarity or higher if the sample is a
further apart that means there are
almost a molarity or a lower so as you
can see into 114 glyphosate samples
close together so then they means they
stay there there's maybe a treatment
effect but let's look at 2015/16 so in
215 now we see the costing of
cultivation but not glyphosate in 2016
we don't see any clustering or pattern
at all so which means we don't like
overall speaking we don't see the
treatment effects in each of each year
of wine sensory properties so also
measure the soil health parameters
including aggregate stability organic
matter accountant microbial respiration
rate and carbon minimize ability so here
in the third year of study in 2016 we
basically see that in the increase of
aggregate stability and organic matter
for the natural vegetation treatment and
it is very easy to understand because if
you just let a way to grow that's the
organic manner that's organic matter and
during the winter they got killed and
it's just a natural improve of or
getting metairie to the soil so if you
have a higher organic matter accountant
then you were expecting a better
microbial activity and also a better
aggregate stability so it's easy to
understand here so in 2000 in :
team also see an increase the microbial
respiration rate in the natural
vegetation and also 2016 compared to the
rest of the treatments and so microbial
respiration is indicator for the
microbial activity in soil so and it is
important because you know you have a
higher microbial activity that means you
will have a higher nutrient immuno as a
minimized mineralization and in your
soil and your it's it's beneficial to
both your plants and the soil so we see
that natural vegetation increased
microbial activity there in both year
and for the carbon memorize ability is
indicator for the nutrient
mineralization the soil and we found
that natural vegetation increased
immunizes ability cover meal as it might
mean arise ability in 2015 so overall
speaking our soil health was improved
throughout the years so to summarize the
physiological perspective that line
vegetative growth fruit composition
basic food composition parameters and
wine sensory properties were not
impacted there's no difference among the
treatments however natural vegetation
treatments basically prove the soil
health so let's look at best look at the
the results from our microbial sunny so
we simple the SONA grapes in the
vineyard we grid simple six soil cores
and ten clusters from each of the
experimental units and then we combine
all the sub simples for each of the
experiment and then we extract the DNA
out of it using those in isolation kids
and we are also interested to see
the wine fermentation microbiome so so
here I want to explain you're very clear
that we only want to capture the effect
of the microbes so we want to get rid of
those great composition variation from
different treatments so what we did was
we obtained a corneal juice from Lansing
that's a Riesling juice and then we
pasteurize it so that's not coming from
our experiment site but it's just a base
juice that we use and we pasteurize it
would kill all the microbes in there and
we use that the base used to arrange 24
cluster is from each of the treatment at
our experimental site so that means we
use so that means we dislodge those
microbes on the surface of the quays
from each of the treatment and then we
use that to do a fermentation to
inoculate the base juice so finally you
know our doing our fermentation the only
difference amount the different batch of
the wine the only difference there is
the microbiome difference and the
difference is coming from the treatment
so we only we we really exclude that
confounding factors of the very
composition difference among the
treatments and then we took samples
throughout the fermentation and the
simple DNA's then sequence used aluminum
I seek and for bacterias we target 16s
region for fungi we target IPS regions
so this is the results before I getting
a result I want to talk to you about the
method we use as you can see here it
says Pico a on axis which represents
principal coordinates analysis so what
we did is we distract a metrics number
in front each of the sample and that
takes
organism relative abundance diversity
and the presents and absence of those
organisms for each you account for each
of the sample and then among all those
samples there's a huge variation so we
extract two dimension that explain the
most variance among the sample and we
use those as our two x's and then we
plot the samples according to those two
x's again this is very company I know a
lot of a lot of you are falling asleep
but just keep in mind that if you see
the samples are further apart that means
their microbial community structure are
less similarity if they're close
together that means they're more similar
to each other so this is the soil
bacterial community structured data for
2014 basically we can see a pattern here
that green dots which is the natural
vegetation on top of here and then
cultivation samples are here they
separate according to the y-axis in 2014
there's they just ran in this together
it's hard to find a pattern here but
until I'm 16 we basically see that the
the blue dots the blue samples and the
green samples they separated and this
these are visual like a visual result
but the visual result were validated
with a paired criminal analysis so
there's a number to actually show that
your visual conception is true so let's
look at 2014 you see that natural
vegetation treatments the soil
composition was very different from
cultivation in quite the state so here
in 2015 there's no pattern as you
remember in the picoway analysis and
yeah it is true there's
different samanda treatment and in 2016
that natural vegetation the green dots
is very different from the glyphosate
which is the blue dot so the overall
male analysis also showed that natural
vegetation really make the bacterial
community structure very different from
that of glyphosate and our cultivation
and soil fungal community you also
analyze that so there are two patterns
you can visual you can find in the
visual results here so first of all the
round stop those round dots are here and
out the square ducts are here and all
the diamond does are in the middle of
the graph so they basically cluster it
based on our x-axis and the shape we
present here so basically our simples
cluster based on year year to year
difference is important here and also
you see there's a colored clustering as
well because all the green paths no
matter it's dark green or light green
they basically separated so you see that
natural vegetation had a huge impact on
the microbial community on the fungal
community structure here and also this
is validated by our appeared from ANOVA
analysis as you can see in 2015-2016
and the overall analysis showed that
each Ana soil fungal community structure
of each of the treatment being
distinctive
so I want to remind you why I wanted to
do this analysis and also we look into
the soil and then we look into the
grapes and wine because many of you have
may have noticed that microbiome in a
wine world as being a really hot topic
there's a lot of good papers coming out
and they all focus on one issue that is
micro biota Gua micro biota was a very
vague term but basically they they
claimed that microbes in the being
marriage or microbes in the wine they
give the wine a sense of location so
what do we want to really look into that
and there are two leaders in United
States they did a lot of the GU research
on this topic including Jack Gilbert's
who came last year she gave a talk
Jackie opers Jackie O Berg's from
University of Chicago and Dave Mills
from UC Davis so for a um Gilbert's
group they found that for vine aerial
Oregon associate microbes there actually
originates originated from the vineyard
soil so what's on the aerial parts
including grapes its originated friend
of soil in abeyance oil but they only
did a bacterial community study so we
want to look into the fungi to see if
that's true for fungi because you know
that it's very different for uh for
fungi and bacteria and thus for size and
the mobility is very different so I want
to see if that's true for fungal
community as well and for that meal
scoop they found a strong association
and mount vineyard site climate and also
the wine fermenting microbiome so want
to study that as well so and so later I
will show you our wine data so that's
why we we sent both from soil grapes to
the Y fermentation so that's looking to
let's look at the grid data we
that is a very clear pattern they
cluster based on shape but if you look
at look into each of the cluster there's
no separation based on the color so they
cluster based on year so years important
vector here but not color treatment so
treatment it's not an important factor
here so the thousand trick triggered the
separation again this data other visual
data is being supported by paired from a
criminal analysis as you can see that
there's no significance among the
treatments for all three years so which
means yes
adopting different underlying soil
management practice really had a great
impact on the soil microbial community
but this does not reflect on what's on
the grapes this is very different from
the previous studies so um we take
samples through all the wine
fermentation so these in 2014 and this
is where we took the sample so day 7 and
day night so Dana is the very beginning
of the presentation as you can see it's
when the sugars start dropping and day
13 which is the back slope is that the
peak of fermentation day 21 as a lay
stage and day 48 that is at the end of
fermentation we so we took the same pose
throughout the fermentation process and
we want to compare the treatments here
so ni notte inoculated means it's just a
fermentation control to see if the
fermentation went wrong or not so we
actually want what we want to compare is
and these treatments here so this is
non-metric and what i damage on sorting
is a very is a different method than the
pee kool-aid but the way to interpret
the data is the same so if you see the
points are close then
microbial community are more similar and
vice-versa so if you see here it's a
very very clear closing pattern that the
simple cluster based on they stay a
fermentation or a station fermentation
but not by treatment here so what we see
here is that the soil microbial
community was heavily impacted by using
different soil management patches and
then this does not reflect on the grapes
so nothing for springing over into the
wine fermentation another interesting
thing that we found is as this so sacrum
I see is always being considered as the
major player during a wine fermentation
what is main is during a wine
fermentation or at least at the peak of
the fermentation the second we see would
present the most in the relative
abundance because as a major player is
doing the workers its equity growing so
the numbers of the sacrum Isis means
that the largest during the fermentation
however in our fermentation what we
found is that hence any Apsara presented
most in relative abundance Theory all
the fermentation and even at the peak of
the fermentation so if you look at the
peak of impatient which is stage 13 it's
around 60% relative abundance whereas
the sacrum is only 15% of 303 of
abundance this is a huge difference and
so that's very different from what we
normally think and from most of the
previous study however we don't know
what the actual function for the $0.10
for us there in the wine fermentation so
just you know just show you this very
interesting results okay so finally the
wine sensory studied for us simulated
spontaneous fermentation so this is the
results so it's very very Rendon
scattered of the samples on the
two-dimensional plot so basically we we
did not see any patterns here so it is a
very reason because we see no difference
of microbial communities and mounded
grapes on the grapes and on the
treatments and also there's no
difference among treatments in the wine
so that the sensory properties were not
impacted is very reasonable and so yeah
that's basically our microbial study
so to summarize it we found that vintage
being them the the may play the major
role there in terms of the microbial
community structure for soils and grapes
and natural vegetation
impacted soil microbial community
structure in terms of the bacteria and
also the fungi and fermentation stage
was the only factor there to trigger the
simple clustering on the two-dimensional
sorting but not the treatments
so the overall wine sensory properties
would not impacted by our underlying
soil treatments here an in conclusion
for our the whole study the undermined
soil management did not impact on plant
growth yelled or the simple berry
composition parameters of the mature
Racine vine aim finger lakes and natural
vegetation generally improve of soil
health as you can see that the parameter
we use soil aggregation organic matter
microbial respiration rate and covering
the rise ability were all in
by using a natural vegetation in terms
of micro microbial community that
undermine soil measurement impact on the
soil bacterial and fungal community but
that effect did not reflect on what's on
a grape and what's in the wine
fermentation so overall speaking there
are no detection on the wine sensor
sensory properties no matter is through
the conventional winemaking no is
through simulated a spontaneous
fermentation so that's uh that's my
study and there's so many people I
wanted to thank through my study here at
Cornell so firstly I want to thank you
short rake Point winery because they
provide me the land to use in to do the
research and they do everything they
could to support us and I want to thank
Steve lurch are a field of sister field
technician and assistant and the people
at Geneva brewing and winemaking lat and
also my previous and my current lab
mates like Adam caribou standing right
there and also my committee member Anna
Katherine Mansfield Jenny Kahn -
Johannes Lehmann and most important of
all my major advisor Justine venerable
who not only helped me through my
research and also make me a much better
person
thank you
I'm going to take questions we'll start
from Geneva and I was just ok
Geneva do you have any questions you may
engage just wondering if you can
describe what your natural vegetation
treatments look like for the weeds three
feet tall 6 feet tall was there any
attempt to control or mow
okay so in 2014 because there there's
some you know the herbicide procedures
in the soil so that that so the lease
were not growing so well however they
got like around 80 centimeter to a meter
tall and we bet we didn't have to molten
down in 2014 but in 2015 they got really
tall so we had to mow them down like
twice in the season so like maximum that
for what I can remember they can get to
around mice in height as me so yeah as
you can get really high really tell for
those especially milk weeds we saw a lot
of milk weeds echo really tall in 2015
in 2016 they're not that aggressive but
we had two more than down once in very
late season does that answer your
question thank you thank you sorry
do we go for Jeanne poppin shorty okay
so please really enjoy your talk I
noticed in many of your analyses years
seem very different you might find a
significant result in 2050 or the first
year but not the second what do you
attribute that kind of variation to I
know it was a drier year but as there
are other sounding factors or how do you
make sense out of the big year
differences you saw so yeah yes I would
consider climate
being the most important factor there
and but there's a lot more than just
climbing so if you look at different
treatments the Wiis growing is is really
different amount a year because of the
climate and also because of the disease
pressure that different year to year so
the like a spraying program are very
different and the way the vineyard crew
managed vineyard were different but i
would say the most important factor
there is because of the climate that
triggers the different weed pressure
different disease pressure so that
resulting a very different data you know
to what extent do you think there's any
motivation then for mature you know
vineyard managers with mature vineyards
to work towards improving soil health
you did since beginning maybe less
leaching of nutrients and pesticides
with their bead to understand are they
fertilizing and the state on losses and
what about self-compassion drink is that
does that matter to them how are your
manager is gonna respond to this yeah
this is a very good question so Jeff and
repeat okay so the question is what's
what's the incentive for the growers to
to use different sort of mentioned
practice because and because basically
we see no difference is that okay yeah
so so so if we think of it another way
around if there's no impact on the yield
or the sensory property why not doing
something that is better for your soil
right so if you adopt a natural
vegetation and you're improving your
soil health that they give that yourself
more resilience to biotic or abiotic
stress then it's it's a good thing for
yourself and for the long term long term
sustainability in terms of financial
sustainability and also the
environmental sustainability and no
matter what you do you're not impacting
on guilt and also not impacting on the
sensory property so so why not so I
think if it's it there would be no like
short turn come over for doing those
kind of practice hallo baby look at it
in the long run it is a good thing for
not protecting your soil also protecting
clean water because you know if those
that the nutrients and pesticides into a
waterway that what gets into our
drinking water and or into the lakes and
it's not good for for those perspectives
to answer your question thank you okay
you mentioned and so it seems like from
your data you disprove that so I'm
wondering is it worth going into that
anymore or you kind of feel like it's a
bit explored enough and it's really just
something that sounds nice that doesn't
exist so the thing is I'm just testing
in our region so it is I will say is
very region specific because a previous
study have shown that vineyard and claim
is playing a major factor there and also
we proved that as well so in our region
specifically what are the obstacles
they're preventing the microbe bill to
war to happen is that we have a really
really big bang so our vines are huge so
that the barrenness spatial barrier from
the soil to the grape is really far away
so even though we have a changing the
micro microbial community in the soil it
is very hard first of all is very hard
to get into the fruiting zone compared
to that say in in France in Burgundy in
Champagne they have their vines are
maybe 30 40 50 centimeter tall so it's
very their cluster are just hanging next
to the soil and there have been studies
showing that
that the mobility of the microbes in the
soil - to the air it's about four for a
fungi especially is around 15 centimeter
so it's really difficult for us to for
the fine china so to move a metre or a
meter 20 centimeter tall to our fruiting
zone so that really prevents those who
show up in our study and also as I've
mentioned that we had very high disease
pressure so we had to spray so many
times in a year and even there's
something getting to including zone it
will very hard for them to either thrive
or to be able to to be alive in the
grapes and then for us to capture it so
I was saying in our specific region here
it is difficult to see and there's those
those reasons but it cannot be applied
to you everywhere in this world it's
really region from region difference is
contributing to that microbial to our
thing Thank You microbes they get on the
outside of the field manipulations yes
you that's you have mentioned most of
the the reason and also like the rain
splash they're studying being show that
the rain splash is playing a playing the
road there and also the the wind is
playing the road there and also like
human as vector to distribute it's also
very important or like so if you could
just explain to people
okay so micro pietà part is so testified
to our furs and I try not to be too big
um tewara is a is basically the sense of
the place in the wine that's why we
called it also you expect even the same
grapes with the same winemaking
techniques people would expect it
differently if you get a California
Pinot Noir or a Finger Lake Pinot Noir
so that gives you a sense of place so
that's the turn up to warrant means and
micro biota warrant is that the what
role does microbes play to give you that
sense of place
so micro po2 are is yeah I think it's
it's worth looking today and we do have
like a spring schedule and what kind of
thought substance they use but for the
harvest so a lot of data were analyzed
at harvest or the same were taken at
harvest before harvest is basically
there's about a week of window with sell
spring right so basically there it's
it's the same so I wouldn't say there
would be so much of a interaction for
that Thanks okay yeah okay
so you were saying the microbes travel
via air is it not going through the root
system and that is a yes so her question
is this microbes only travel through the
air does it not travel through the plan
and the answer is yes it does travel
through the plane so there's a lot of
the especially bacteria there's a lot of
them made into the plants and that
triggers the second plant or the vine
and grapes secondary metabolites a
synthesis so yes there's a lot of those
and that's I think that's important for
our next step to see so now we see that
it's not impacting the wine sensory
properties and what is there to trigger
the wine sensory differences in the end
of very study a very first study I
showed so we can really look into those
endophytes to see if they are playing
the trick here to really make the wine
sensory properties different thank you
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu